hi i'm christine goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
social media flooded with reactions to
violent protesters breaching the u.s
capitol building
what can congressional leaders do to
curb the anger swelling across the
nation
and restore faith in the fairness of the
american system of democracy
republican congresswoman kat kamika
florida and michigan democratic
congresswoman alyssa slotkin weigh in
on what lawmakers should do to rebuild
confidence in the election system
and heal the country the democratic
party taking control of congress and the
white house
for the first time in a decade fox news
sunday host chris wallace discusses
what this means for the biden
administration and the future
of america plus commentary from fox news
contributor deroy murdock
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe
on your favorite podcast player by going
to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm janis dean i'm david asman i'm dana
parino and this is the fox news rundown
[Music]
friday january 8th 2021
on lisa brady president trump has
conceded
and he's calling for unity an appeal
also coming from both sides in congress
after the attack on the u.s capitol i
think the greatest threat to americans
right now
all americans is the division between us
i'm
confident that we will move past this
and we will be stronger tomorrow
as americans rather than one party
versus the other
i'm chris foster some of president
trump's supporters are turning their
backs after wednesday's right at the
capitol
if you're a republican looking to
run for election yeah there's a danger
of a primary from the right
if you're a republican but in terms of
an election i gotta think
the support of donald trump is is uh
costs more than it's worth we speak with
fox news sunday host chris wallace
and i'm deroy murdock i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
more than two months after election day
president trump acknowledges
it's over a new administration will be
inaugurated on january 20th
my focus now turns to ensuring a smooth
orderly and seamless transition of power
this moment calls for healing and
reconciliation
he posted this video message thursday
night after a lock on his twitter
account was lifted
he also said serving as president has
been the honor of his lifetime and wants
supporters to know
the incredible journey is only just
beginning but he started the message by
condemning
wednesday's violent siege of the u.s
capitol calling it a heinous attack and
saying he's outraged
like all americans the demonstrators who
infiltrated the capital
have defiled the seat of american
democracy
to those who engage in the acts of
violence and destruction
you do not represent our country and he
says those who broke the law
will pay some members of congress accuse
the president
of inciting the violence and they want
him out of office
now in calling for this seditious act
president has committed an unspeakable
assault on our nation
and our people i joined the senate
democratic leader in calling on the vice
president
to remove this president by immediately
invoking the 25th
amendment if vice president mike pence
and the
cabinet don't act house speaker nancy
pelosi says there may be another
impeachment effort though it's not clear
just how quickly that could be done
president-elect joe biden staying out of
that discussion as he condemned the
attack again
on thursday they weren't protesters
don't dare call them protesters they
were
a riotous mob insurrectionist
domestic terrorist some republicans have
also criticized the president a few
even joining the call to remove him from
office but south carolina republican
senator lindsey graham
says there should have been a stronger
response to other protests that turned
violent
the mistake we made is when people tried
to destroy the
courthouse in portland they weren't
prosecuted the full extent of law
when they occupied seattle they weren't
prosecuted to the full extent of the law
so the appeal for national unity may
have a long way to go
even in the damaged halls of congress
there's been a lot of dangerous rhetoric
that quite frankly is just not helpful
of
finger pointing and playing the blame
game
congresswoman kat kamak is new to
capitol hill a freshman republican
lawmaker from florida
we need to focus on what comes next
and for me that is getting to work on
behalf of the constituents that we've
been sent
to washington by and i think it's
so important that we all just as we have
denounced the violence
uh throughout the the year uh burning
and rioting and looting of our cities
we need to denounce the violence that
took place and
and began to look for answers who
exactly were the people
that uh breached the capital and and
finding out um which groups they were
affiliated with an investigation needs
to be done
in its entirety and a very thorough one
we need to look
at security breaches that took place and
and really start to dig into the safety
of
complex the safety of the chamber and
for members
there's just too many questions that
that need to be answered at this point
in time
and my my hope and prayer is that palmer
head will prevail in all of this
what about these calls for removing the
president
from office i mean there there are some
lawmakers who say he's
dangerous and and shouldn't be allowed
to stay for these last
you know couple of weeks this is getting
to a point of
uh insanity we're two weeks away
from a peaceful transition of power the
president issuing the statement
reinforcing that we will have a peaceful
transfer of power
and and efforts like this you know the
25th amendment
commission called like this when when
we're in such a
short window in this transition phase
they're just not helpful
i think when we start getting into this
very dangerous rhetoric that's where
poor decisions
uh begin uh to be made and
and we have a duty first and foremost to
protect the constitution we swore to
uphold
we need to be focusing on those core
basic tenants
uh and foundations of our country rather
than trying to
further uh push our country into this
divide
are you as a republican are you
you know any less optimistic
now that the democrats are going to
control
the white house the house and it looks
like the senate as well
um are you you know especially as a new
republican member of congress how do you
feel about that are you
do you have mixed emotions are you still
you know
holding out hope that people can get
along and get things accomplished
well you know of course uh it is a very
difficult situation coming into
um being in the minority where you know
the democrats now control the house
unfortunately the senate and
unfortunately the white house
but i am optimistic in the house
particularly that
the democrats have the narrowest margin
that they've ever had
since world war ii which means speaker
pelosi cannot steamroll republicans as
we saw
very plainly she just simply doesn't
have the numbers and their fractures
within their side
so much so that she had to fly in a
coveted positive member to secure her
speakership
that tells me that they are going to
need us
far more than we're going to need them
to come
to us on pieces of legislation so
i'm optimistic that we will have
opportunities to work
uh together to get the things done that
our constituents have
asked us to work on that's why we're
here to get things done
not to continually fight the other side
and ultimately try to tear down the very
institution that we've sworn to protect
so i think for us as republicans getting
back to the basics
really getting back to this idea and
concept
that we are the party of equal
opportunity
not equal outcome and fighting for those
principles
uh that we hold so dear
i think we have made tremendous gains in
the last four years
you know no one can take away the fact
that president trump
expanded our base really brought uh
different
uh opinions into the fold and and made
headway
into some of these key demographic
groups so
we're going to continue to build on that
we've seen a shift
with the democrats to the to the far
left
and they have some some soul searching
to do on their side of things but
regardless i have to say that i do
remain optimistic
because if we don't have optimism in
what we're doing
then what the heck are we doing so i
i'm i'm confident that we will move past
this and we will be stronger tomorrow
as americans rather than one party
versus the other
there's a simmering debate though about
whether certain protesters are treated
differently than others
in addition to the many questions about
wednesday's massive security breach
we need to have a discussion we need to
have a whole after-action
kind of review on what happened here we
spoke with michigan democratic
congresswoman alyssa slotkin
thursday afternoon i mean you know i
really think of
of uh yesterday as sort of a very
important
even generational event i mean i think
most americans
will remember what they were doing or
where they were who they were they were
with when they heard that the
capital had been breached and there was
you know people
armed folks inside the capitol um and
for for a while
it was quite dicey um i think the vast
majority of americans the vast majority
of trump voters do not
support um the use of violence um
to uh achieve political goals and i i
hope
it's a stark reminder to everybody that
you know
we are one america we have a shared
destiny we are
all on this boat together and we have to
figure out
how to communicate again how to build up
the relationships between us
and i see that very clearly as someone
who's you know a democrat who represents
a trump voting district
you know my neighbors think very
differently than i do my in-laws think
very
differently than i do on politics but we
can't let that
tear us apart or else we're done here
we're done there was a fox news voter
analysis
that found seven out of ten republicans
believe the november election was
inaccurately certified how do we rebuild
confidence
in the election system for sure and this
i say
you know as someone who believes in our
system and is invested in our system
um it is not okay um if people do that
people
don't believe in our system anymore
that's a threat to the system
so whether i agree with people who think
that president trump won or not
it is vitally important that we do a
real
thorough review of our election system
in a bipartisan and transparent way so
that everyone knows what's going on
so that we can improve any
irregularities any
problems um and people can feel faith
in in the system again i i in in my
state the secretary of state has
committed to doing a bipartisan
lessons learned on the 2020 election and
then
attacking the problem again democrats
and republicans together
where there's any problems or or
inconsistencies in the system
so that kind of thing i'm in full
support of and do i think that
you know that donald trump really won
the state of michigan i don't but do i
realize it's important
to make sure that all my michigander
citizens all americans feel invested in
our democracy
absolutely one other question because i
know
you're a former cia analyst as well
and from an intelligence an
investigative perspective i'm wondering
what you think of the assessment of the
dc mayor and others who
are calling this attack domestic
terrorism
the use or threat of violence for
political goals
is the definition of terrorist the
definition it's just in the dictionary
um and when a protest which is
everyone's first amendment right
when a protest turned violent trying
to overturn uh the democratic process
that was going on
in congress that is the definition of
domestic terrorism and it's
it's not i'm not saying that as a
political statement i'm saying that as a
textbook case study and i i certainly
feel like yesterday was the end
of sort of the post 9 11 era right the
20 years since 9 11
where people like me with the national
security background have been focusing
on
external threats foreign terrorist
groups countries like
china um and russia and north korea
i think the greatest threat to americans
right now all americans
is the division between us is the
divisiveness in the country
and the threat that that poses us as a
nation
not just today tomorrow but long term
michigan democratic congresswoman alyssa
slotkin
i'm glad you're safe and thank you since
for spending some time with us
thank you
this is deroy murdock with your fox news
commentary coming up
it's the end of well quite a week in
politics in america
joe biden has his electoral college
victory affirmed by congress with the
count announced by vice president pence
the votes for president of the united
states are as follows
joseph r biden jr of the state of
delaware has received 306 votes
donald j trump of the state of florida
has received 232 votes
democrats rafael warnock and john ossoff
win both senate runoff elections in
georgia
georgia i am honored by the faith that
you have shown
in me it is with humility that i thank
the people of georgia for electing me to
serve you in the united states senate
thank you for the confidence and trust
that you have placed in me that means
democrats will now control the senate
house and white house when
president-elect biden takes office in 12
days
so what happened wednesday that most
americans will never forget
the ride at the united states capital
during that joint session to affirm joe
biden's victory
by people claiming the election was
rigged and stolen from president trump
we got here by a president who kept
pushing
the envelope further and further broke
through the envelope
chris wallace is the host of fox news
sunday he shut out the people
who would have tried to to stop him to
restrain him to tell him things he
didn't want to hear
and he surrounded himself with a bunch
of sycophants uh we got here by
politicians who decided i think often
times most times
uh for their own cynical political
purposes
said things they didn't believe did
things they knew were wrong
uh to try to uh play to the trump base
and i think we got here because of uh
social media and the media
and people who thought it was cynically
in their
advantage to uh to side with the
president
and particularly in terms of since the
election
to propagate these absolutely baseless
theories of widespread election fraud
yeah i mean my reaction at first glance
how shocking it was
is how shocking it wasn't and that it
almost seemed inevitable given the
president's language to his supporters
since the election especially over the
last couple of weeks i guess
last month when it became clear he
wasn't getting any love from the courts
and then just the general sense of anger
in the country anyway over the last year
i have to tell you i watched his speech
on the
on the mall on on wednesday when he went
on for more than an hour
and talked about we will never concede
we will never accept this
we'll going to march down to the capitol
of course he didn't he got in his
limousine and went back to the opal
office uh and i thought to myself this
is a guy just
flinging a a a a match on
burning you know on on dry timber it did
i expect that they were gonna take over
the capitol no
a guy you know i'd never i couldn't
imagine that
because i'd never seen it in my life but
did i think it was going to lead to
trouble
and confrontations and and violence
absolutely
um it got and it ended up so much worse
than you know even my deepest darkest uh
concerns about what was going to happen
yeah i heard you use
um the word desecration and i think
that's that's apt
it's it was it was gross yeah you know i
i'm i've been telling this story today
that that uh
when i my first job in washington i it
back in 1978 for nbc news as i was
covering the u.s senate
and every morning the senate majority
leader a democrat from west virginia
named bobby byrd he would
he would call the reporters onto the
floor of the senate
to tell it what was the schedule for
that day what was going to happen
and i could never pay attention i always
had to get a fill from my colleagues
because i would just i was on the floor
of the u.s senate and i was looking over
and thinking that was
that was jack kennedy's desk and and
looking over and that was
you know henry clay's desk and lyndon
johnson's and harry truman's and you
know on and on
and uh i i was so
thrilled to to be there and to to watch
these thugs these anarchists these
terrorists uh roaming the floor of the
u.s
senate uh sitting in the chair of the
presiding officer the chair that the
vice president
mike pence had sat in uh an hour before
you know this is this was absolutely the
desecration
of a of of of a place of of religion and
effective our civic religion
a citadel of democracy and and they ran
rampant there for hours
and forced out members of the house
members of the senate
who were there fulfilling their
constitutional duty under article two
uh to to count the vote and they were
running for their lives because they
were worried the mob was going to seize
them
um are donald trump and mike pence ever
going to speak again pence was loyal
vice president as you can imagine at
least publicly
but in the end anybody you know what
isn't
anybody that is on the map it doesn't
matter you know if it doesn't matter
because
uh you know
in in the end mike pence did so many
things
for donald trump over the course of the
four years had to sit there at things
that you
knew he was horrified by and play play
the loyal soldier
and then you know in the ultimate and
and there was no choice look he had
anybody who reads the constitution and
i've spent more time than i care to
think about reading article two of the
constitution the 12th amendment
the 1887 electoral vote count
uh there's no way under any
interpretation except for
these loony people who the president
surrounded himself with
uh to think that that pence could
unilaterally
overthrow the results of the election
and would we want a vice president to be
able to overthrow the results of the
election
and so pence says no i can't do that
which
is something he blatantly can't do and
the president has ticked to them
why would you know whether they talk or
they don't talk it doesn't matter i
think they both showed who they were
we've talked a lot about how much
influence president trump might have
later down you know from the sidelines
you've got to think it's a lot less
a lot less now absolutely and
and probably not for the right reasons
you know
i mean the right reason would be that
that the president abdicated such
you know i mean you're seeing people
leaving with days left to go
you know but that that's not the reason
that i think his
that his influence is gonna is gonna
really wane i think it's because
he's he's almost got reverse coattails
now i think he's a drag
on on the party you know i know people
have lived in fear of the trump base and
they're still big
and you're not going to want to take
them on but look what happened in
georgia
you know he went down there and he
you know i think he's probably if you're
a republican
looking to run for election yeah there's
a danger of a primary from the right
if you're a republican but in terms of
an election i kind of think
the support of donald trump is is uh
costs more than it's worth you know that
had it has a
in a cost benefit analysis it ends up as
a net negative
yeah well uh like those two wins in
georgia mean democrats take control of
congress it's slim margins in both
houses but
slims better than none or deficit what
difference do you see those wins in
georgia making to
president biden well i think it'll make
a big difference in some things for
i think that for instance in terms of
getting his cabinet through
getting judges appointed it'll have an
enormous
impact because you know that that that
rule has been changed it
simply takes a simple majority of 51
votes and with kamala harris breaking
the tie
there'll be 51 votes so i think that's
one of the reasons incidentally that you
suddenly saw the the the biden camp
announced that they're
going to name federal district judge
merrick garland federal uh circuit court
judge
merrick garland as the u.s attorney one
that they'll be able to get him through
and two that they're going to be able to
get through a replacement
for for garland on the circuit court of
appeals
on a lot of big issues a lot of big
legislative issues
i'm not sure that it will make such a
difference um and i say that because i
think
that i think it's going to be very hard
and i'm not sure one uh
fiden is an institutionalist will push
for it and two i'm not sure he'd have
the votes in the senate
to get it through to end the filibuster
so on legislative issues where you need
60 votes not 51
i'm not sure it'll make a difference i
where i think it's i think it's going to
prevent
a lot of obstruction from the
republicans and i think it's going to
really empower the center
people like joe manchin and maybe susan
collins and lisa murkowski
in the republican party to you know
let's find the things we can agree on
whether it's infrastructure or
two thousand dollar direct payments you
know we're not gonna
overhaul the green new deal we're not
gonna you know be able to
to do some things on health care but
there are some things things that we can
do
and maybe we'll get those done and i
would also think after
after this week that there's going to be
a huge desire on the part of the
of the the right thinkers correct
thinkers in the house and the senate
we've got to show america that we're not
as bad as this that we can accomplish
some things
put some points on the board yeah uh
chris wallace here's the better days
host of fox news sunday good to talk to
you chris thank you
thank you chris
[Music]
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network in
these ever-changing times
you can rely on fox news for hourly
updates for the very latest news and
information
on your time listen and download now at
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you get
your favorite podcasts
rate and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
an act of kindness by one minnesota
restaurant's customers is turning a
theft
into a show of support natalie victoria
who owns a restaurant and wine bar in
rochester minnesota says the pandemic
has been hard enough on her industry
but the recent theft of her business's
tip drawer just added insult to injury
k-a-a-l-t-v in rochester reports that
two women came into the restaurant
placed a complicated order then when no
one was around
natalie says they made off with the tip
money about 300
she says she wasn't angry but she was
disappointed when she looked at the
security tapes
her thoughts were with the restaurant
staff who had already been hit hard by
the pandemic
word of the theft spread on social media
and the community rallied
the shea family were some of the people
who were saddened by the incident
and the young boys in that family
decided to do something about it
bronson carter rowan ryan and bennett
shea pooled their money
about 200 dollars they'd saved from
working over the summer last year
and delivered the cash to the wait staff
along with a card
natalie says it almost brought her staff
to tears the boys
say it was just great to be able to help
out tanya j
powers fox news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
murdock what's on your mind it's hard to
express the shock and sadness i felt
wednesday seeing
america's legislative palace breached a
door to the u.s house floor broken
and senators and congressmen hunkering
down some in gas masks
most astonishing was to see those
committing this violence waving not
antifa flags but instead
trump and mega banners it would have
been bad enough if this mob perpetrated
these acts of domestic terrorism
while house speaker nancy pelosi
democrat of california banger gavel and
shut down any objections to electoral
college votes
that many of my fellow trump fans
believe are tainted by fraud
and other irregularities 180 degrees on
the contrary
the senate and house were debating
republican objections to arizona's
electoral college votes
senator ted cruz republican of texas was
making his constitutionalist case to his
colleagues with his usual eloquence
congressman andy biggs republican of
arizona head of the freedom caucus
rose to express his concerns about his
own state's
electoral college votes congressman
biggs even presented something that
should not have existed
a stack of voter registrations that were
approved after the grand canyon state's
statutory deadline this is just the sort
of vote fraud evidence
that the president's supporters have
wanted for weeks to be aired in public
thus the sheer mind-blowing stupidity of
the buffoons who stormed the capital
they attacked congress exactly as it was
doing precisely
what these people wanted done this would
be akin to antifa breaking through the
windows of the capital
just as a democratic u.s senate voted on
final passage
of vermont social senator bernie sanders
medicare for all act of 2021
dum dum dum dum dum with guns drawn on
the us house floor
and an astonishing four people dead this
was the most vicious breach of the
capital
since the british army burned it down to
the ground in 1814
during the darkest hour of the war of
1812.
in an astonishing act of self-sabotage
these idiots now have made it enormously
difficult
for those of us who admire president
donald j trump for his enormous domestic
and international policy victories
instead any discussion
of the man who inspired the highest
median household income in american
history
the lowest poverty rate ever the
complete liquidation of the isis
caliphate
and two covet 19 vaccines in nine months
will be answered with oh you mean the
boob whose brutes assaulted the us
capital
these un-american anarchists have
performed an enormous disservice to
president trump
the america first movement roughly 75
million voters who cast our ballots for
him in november
and our beloved united states of america
those who invaded the capitol need to
ponder the evil destruction and death
that they committed the capital police
and dc metropolitan police
should arrest everyone who is in
violation of local and federal laws
especially those who are photographed
dangling from a balcony over the senate
floor
sitting in the chair on the senate dais
and grinning behind nancy pelosi's desk
these barbarians should be prosecuted
and if convicted
imprisoned for the maximum terms allowed
by law
president trump did the right thing
wednesday afternoon he issued a video
statement from the white house via
twitter and told his overzealous backers
to beat it
after hours of chaos they finally heeded
his words
i know how you feel but go home and go
home in peace
now these bumps should stay home ponder
the devastation they brought to our
capital and our cause
and await law enforcement's knocks on
their front doors
i'm deroy
you've been murdock to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
[Music]
did you hear the news now you can with
instant updates from fox news for amazon
alexa
just say alexa play news from fox
in fox news it's the latest when you
need it
on demand from fox news and amazon alexa
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes